I'm joined today by Malcolm Harris who's
a philadelphia-based freelance writer
and author of kids these days human
capital and the making of Millennials
I've been reading quite a bit lately
Malcolm about the topic of Millennials
it's a popular issue for people that are
Millennials and people that are not
Millennials to write about and there's
sort of like two general trends I see
two types of writing about Millennials
one is the very critical this is a lazy
generation this is a generation that is
not made up of makers but it's takers
etc that's one sort of line the other is
Millennials are a generation that like
no other are burdened by exploding
student debt stagnant wages a not
particularly great job market in the
sense that more and more education is
required even for jobs that previously
did not require such high levels of
education my instinct is the truth is
probably a combination of the two and
and many other things what is your sort
of general take on the existence of
Millennials in 2017 well it sort of goes
back to how you define a generation and
the way I'm looking at it in my book is
as this age cohort roughly between 1980
and 2000 but what's most important isn't
the year range it's how were responding
to trends and crises and the dominant
social forms that are occurring during
our lifetime so what I see is the the
main sort of shaping force in the
Millennial experience is the increasing
rate of exploitation the divergence
between average compensation and average
worker productivity and when you say
when you say that that that difference
we've looked at the minimum wage that
that we should have today had it tracked
inflation the minimum wage that we
should have today had it tracked
productivity since 1968 but what you're
saying is that it's a more acute
difference a more acute departure
between wages and productivity among
Millennials than among any other age
cohort absolutely well and as we watch
that trend in that divergence from the
60s and 70s 50s even it grows as we keep
going and so the leader you are as a
cohort in this development the more
you're going to experience it and the
more it's going to affect your
development as a worker but also as a
person as a citizen are there any other
characteristics of the modern economy
that you would look at in trying to
understand the place of Millennials
compared to older cohorts of workers
absolutely and there are a lot that I do
human capital development and its role
in education and job training is a huge
part of it a job polarization the growth
of bad jobs is a huge part temporary
work contracts the deregulation of
worker protections all of these things
are part of the same trend and a common
thread we can see in all of them is the
successful effort to push labor costs
down what are some ways in which the
Millennials that are succeeding are
succeeding that differ from or at least
are opportunities that only exist in the
2017 economy that did not previously
exist or or I guess what I'm saying is
in a different way
how have the more successful Millennials
use the unique characteristics of the
modern economy to sort of separate
themselves from the suppression of wages
well the best way is to own things and
so the more whether it's inherited
wealth in a lot of cases it is or owning
shares whether you you buy into a
business again most of this is not
through labor is the best way to succeed
in the 21st century economy is not to be
a worker at all it's to be a capitalist
and that involves owning things so the
what we call the successful Millennials
which is a small group a shrinking group
in fact
succeeds mostly by owning things when
you look at the cost of college and
what's going on with student lending and
the cost of college compared to wages
upon graduation is this even remotely
sustainable I I talked to friends all
the time about how can these trends
continue because even just 5 or 10 years
from now even the the the it seems as
though it would be completely outrageous
to even take on the debt required for
even something like a liberal arts
degree which statistically speaking it
is not going to really put you in a good
place to pay back those loans talk about
the role of what's going on with cost of
college in this situation the worry
actually for me having done the research
is that it is sustainable and that the
system can go on so well I'm serious
because one of the things we've seen
over time is the increase in value of
the college premium in wages so it makes
a bigger difference whether you go to
college or not that actually has not
been driven by gains in wages for
college educated but falling wages for
those with without a college education
and so it's fear that it's going to keep
driving people into college but unlike
the housing market where if you're over
leveraged on your house you can walk
away you can't do that when it comes to
human capital debt when it comes to
education debt there's no way to walk
away from the loans and so once you take
them out you will pay them back
eventually even the Treasury has to pry
it out of your social security checks
which they will do so the the system as
it exists can be sustained and can in
fact get much much worse without
collapsing is that what you see is
happening I mean do you do you not see
that there's going to be anything that
will either for political reasons or
economic reasons reverse this trend that
we're seeing of this explosion of not
only the the sort of retail price of a
college education but also the ease with
which one can get loans to cover those
exploded prices yeah I don't see any any
reversal happening we haven't seen that
it's not in the numbers we don't see any
sort of mechanisms any effective
attempts to drive down the cost of
attending college there have been some
attempts to sort of halt the rate of
increase which I think has to do more
with eating the peak of the ceiling of
what people can actually pay but it'll
keep going up I think it will continue
so economic circumstances aside do you
think there's any validity to some of
the other criticisms or at least
explanations that some put forward as to
why millenials are so different than all
prior modern generations for example
smartphone use that represents a sort of
different relationship to the device
than any previous generation had the age
of the internet for example a
globalization I mean you take take your
pick are there any of these more
cultural explanations that you think
hold water no I really don't Jeanne
twins another scholar and she's quoted
in the book about generational
difference although she's more of a
consultant these days and her book IGN
puts forward this idea that generation
the next generation be after Millennials
which she calls ijen it's also the name
of her consulting company that this
generation this cohort has been shaped
by cellphones directly and I read the
book that's that's really her whole
argument but the trends I'm looking at
go back to the late 70s early 80s the
economic trends and so we're not looking
at something that starts in in the 2000s
we're looking at something that started
decades ago with phenomenon that a lot
of commenters commentators like to call
neoliberalism these are the consequences
and phones have become a part of that
lifestyle part of the practice of
neoliberalism but we shouldn't confuse
it with the cause what do you see as
sort of the generational pass-through of
what's currently going on with
Millennials as more and more Millennials
now have kids and will be having kids in
the next three to five years
distally anyway how will the children of
Millennials be in
by what's going on I hope it's too soon
to tell because if we just extend the
trends of our experience further another
couple decades it gets really scary very
quickly and people are going to have a
hard time an increasingly difficult time
raising happy well-adjusted children
into this world into America if there is
some fundamental social political shift
in the next few decades which i think is
definitely a possibility then those
conditions change yeah I mean what
you're describing really should point to
Millennials being the most activist
minded generation in a long time given
how disproportionately some of these
issues are affecting Millennials is that
borne out in the data are we seeing that
aside from sort of what we've observed
for a long time which is that younger
generations tend to be more progressive
than older generations and that's sort
of how they vote are we actually seeing
a higher rate of voting among those who
are currently millennial aged than we
saw previously among the older
generations when they were millennial
aged I don't think it's that much about
voting
I think voting has become a a debased
form of political involvement and
yong-ki this younger cohort is skeptical
of that process also voting young people
voting youth voting is not that old 18
year-olds have not had the franchise for
many generational cohorts so I'm not
sure that's the best mode of
longitudinal comparison what would one
appoint you or what would you look at I
think we have seen a more politically
active active sophisticated cohort of
young people than we've seen in a long
time absolutely you know we look at the
the situation the political situation
the economic situation and think wow
there should be you know huge protests
of young people on every American city
this should be you know a nationwide
movement and there was we had Occupy
where that was a thing that happened
and that's what motivated it and since
then we've had a different kind of
discussion in this country in terms of
economic inequality in terms of how
capitalism works and young people more
and more are finding positions outside
the political mainstream that appeal to
them how are they turning that into
activism in the most or how could they
turn that into real-world change through
activism what types of active attactive
ism would be most successful and you've
already pointed out vote voting is not
it well if I had that answer
I'd be going doing that instead of
writing books I guess well you could be
doing both right I mean if you had if
you have an idea I'd be curious what it
is what would be the other avenues so
one of the things I do in the conclusion
of my book is look at a couple avenues
that were taught are the useful ways of
political engagement how we're supposed
to change our society whether that's
volunteerism or voting or the market or
protest demonstrative protest and I sort
of go through all four of those and show
how I don't think they can work in the
timeframe in which we need them to work
in this country I think we've got really
a limited a couple decades in which to
make really huge fundamental changes to
our society or else we're screwed or
else it doesn't matter and so what we
call it when the fundamental mode of
society is transformed is revolution and
so that's the kind of change that we
need in America I think we've been
talking about the book kids these days
human capital and the making of
Millennials the book's author is Malcolm
Harris Malcolm thanks so much for
talking to us about this thanks for
having me David